so those out there on the frontlines of
this of this war god bless you and we're
gonna keep playing music for you in one
way or another whether that's on our
iPhones or on this stage the circle will
not be broken despite the ongoing
coronavirus pandemic yeah grand ole opry
members Vince Gill Brad Paisley and
Marty Stewart kept the music playing for
fans all around the world Saturday night
for the show's four thousand nine
hundred and sixteenth consecutive
broadcast you're not supposed to say the
word cancer
the song
and telling folks that Jesus is the
answer can rub them wrong
[Music]
it ain't hip to sing I'm bound tractors
trucks and little towns mama yeah I
guess that's true but this is country
music we do
country music it's no stranger to hard
times you know and the Grand Ole Opry is
no stranger to our taxes it's 94 years
old been through world wars catastrophes
presidential assassinations leaders
assassinated but somehow the show has
always just gone right alone and almost
never gone off the air and Merle Haggard
and I used to talk about Jimmie Rodgers
the father of country music I didn't
know if I believe that or not until I
bought his box set in the courts and I
listened to every song I get it yes sir
you're the man and it's the subject
matter right Vince exactly in the songs
it's it's set up the whole empire up
country music it always has you know I
think that we're at our best I think
during hard times you know as sad as
these times are that we're kind of going
through right now
what's the silver lining of the beauty
or the the blessing and all of it is
that we're all kind of all gathering
around our families and all gather
around people we love and and kind of
circling you know and finding our way
through and and there's a beauty in that
that was just this whole last week I've
been home with Amy the whole time and
it's just been amazing keeping a safe
distance from one another the three long
serving members of the Opry delivered a
beautiful acoustic set of songs which
included an emotional cover of Kenny
Rogers sweet music man as a tribute to
the late country music legend who passed
away Friday evening at the age of 81
senior song sweet music man
travelers six-piece pain it does for you
what you ask come to me and you try to
stay on with the songs you some to so
many people live all begun to come back
[Music]
to sing your song
sweet music me you're making a living
doing one-night stands to prove to you
[Music]
it'll need you still a hell of a singing
I'm on a broken man you keep looking for
one last favor sing to
nobody sings a love song quite like you
do nobody else can make me sing alone
nobody else can make me feel things are
right when I know they're wrong nobody
sings a love song quite like you
[Music]